you know what's weird though it's like
we're definitely like dying as a channel
but like we're growing and our
subscribers as we're dying yeah so what
do you think that means it's an oxymoron
I'd say yeah like is that what it means
six months Nick start making plans
[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boy where it's
now 2023 even though this video is
coming out like
okay so number one how do any of us get
[ __ ] done when we are all kind of bosses
in like our own thing and we all were
[ __ ] late today not all of us dude
did anyone remember you were supposed to
meet at nine cannon cannon this guy
no credit no credit you were still late
you son of a [ __ ] how was I late bro
all right with everyone hold on if
everyone was here if everyone was here
at nine you would have been late because
you came at 9 13. do you act like we
that's so late dude what's your problem
I was definitely not here at 9 15. you
guys both you boys were pooping for at
least 10 minutes before like I walked in
oh just wait till later too I'll be
pooping in [ __ ] 10th
it's a [ __ ] 10 15 dude Anthony was
telling me you barely woke up when he
got here I woke up but I wasn't late
to be honest I think Anthony is probably
the bossest of us though yeah I agree I
agree because I think me and Joe find
excuses to just set up more clubhouses I
don't know if they're really businesses
but I think Anthony the way he sets
things up it's like it's pretty
structured and organized he's always so
shout out staff he's always trying to be
efficient all the time
give a quick shout out to Anthony
I just want to do a quick [ __ ] that's my
boy
right here Anthony Lee I'm about to
write my obituary yeah shout out to this
dude right here man
hey Anthony
well that's what happens like you said
when Michael's no longer here you know
what I mean I obviously we feel the
sting of him not being here we love you
Mike he was the true boss yeah he was a
real boss true boss even though we still
don't know how many articles we got to
do today because he thought he's like
the real he's the real June towel
do you think the commenters will be like
it just hasn't been the same since
Michael left
dude I hope so I hope so I hope that's a
comment is he gonna make a why I left JK
video I hope so you gotta milk it he's
got to well I love chicken you get six
figs views get a nice little check get a
nice little 720 dollars
on the way out I know you get like 724s
half a million views
yeah on the way out you have a nice
little I know I am it's a good three or
more that's a 30 year mortgage right and
then people stop watching your videos
immediately afterwards I know because
they don't well but you have to maybe
you can milk it a little bit more you
can like uh there was another time a JK
like Bart stepped on my foot
you got to like cut up you'll really
ring that thing out get racial somehow
that's the funny thing it's not like
BuzzFeed where you actually get a career
after you make a why I left video
yeah unfortunately it just goes down
from after you leave hey but good for
those guys though we're gonna change
that we're gonna change that this year
we're gonna make it so when you leave JK
you have a chance after that'd be sick
that means JK has to be real severance
package yeah
I gotta give props you know shout outs
to Ryan shout out to Ryan what are we
doing now because you can't make fun of
me
and he was late he just assumed that
everybody was already here so he booked
it he got here in five minutes from his
downtown spot and he moved so fast he
ran every red light and he left his
phone and didn't go back for it so he
doesn't have a phone
[Applause]
dude in my mind I really thought you
guys are all just sitting here and then
there's just like a blank chair and I
was like [ __ ] man way to endanger the
lives of other people on the road
you come to a shitty [ __ ] video for
21 000 people
you 11 000 of them are re-watches on the
red light in your van no in the in like
Honda oh he's not okay that [ __ ] would
be good
yeah no and and I ran pretty fast from
them I love everyone's response too I
everyone was like wait what this one
didn't even pick up the phone he was
sleeping I wasn't sleeping how could I
possibly even sleep and then get here 10
minutes later [ __ ] I thought it
was more than 10 minutes his first text
was LOL what yeah well thankfully I was
already I was like ready to go basically
so I was just like I'll go get my
[ __ ] Uber now that's I thought it was
like early I was like should I get
donuts for everybody like what should I
do with this extra time I have you got
up early yeah can calls me 9 27 a.m I
was here what nine
38.
that's pretty good man yeah is that
gonna be really good also right when I
went to McDonald's because I was like
you guys all deserve McDonald's except
for the late people so that's why we're
eating McDonald's we got treated this is
a good hash brown we got to have
McDonald's now I can't afford McDonald's
to just cut my pay that's true hopefully
in 2023 it'll come back around be on
time you get McDonald's next time New
Year's resolution no Joe said we're not
getting our uh our payback because uh we
got demonetized that's another thing oh
let's talk about it let's talk about it
there's cussing now it's gonna
demonstrate it's already happening I
went on to travel yeah 30 seconds or
whatever I don't think so yeah we have
to be very good at that I'm pretty sure
we did first 30 seconds this one's
already demonetized we already Cuts in
the first 30. so what happened we were
mindful that's another rule we thought
we were gonna follow
we tried so hard though but then editors
people editors can bleep right [ __ ] oh
yeah they can can we babe I shout out to
Ryan man yeah yeah
big brain stuff more work for the
editors so do we do you guys want to try
clutching less or just have editors
bleep everything let's try to do both
let's try to be sick well if they're
gonna slip we could bleep it yeah like
maybe it'll be a good exercise for us
but people come here for the cussing I
know that's why they come here for the
cussing you can't go okay
you Olive Garden and they go We're not
gonna have pasta anymore [ __ ] or
breadsticks
[Laughter]
come here for that man that's like you
go to the Olive Garden and there's no
atmosphere yeah
I know can you imagine them saying that
to you at the host Podium like as if
they know that's what you want and they
don't have it hey buddy we don't have no
uh breadsticks or nothing thanks for
coming if they did that honestly you
would see brawls at all hell yeah
they're like that's what they go for
yeah if they took out the breadsticks
you would see brawl say brawl of garden
say it brawlive oh
but isn't it also it's also like content
like uh not just cussing but like if we
say something to uh raunchy or perverted
in general how will the algorithm know
that yeah it knows it knows old enough
for kisses not good and there's no
cussing in that like now you can't even
say old enough for kisses in sequence
but that's because he's kissing a small
girl
the [ __ ] Benjamin Button thing you
know I don't think that doesn't see no
that would make sense Brad bill is still
regular sized I know that's the sad
thing is it the uncle always picks that
up and then it age Gates that video
every time yeah I think for good reason
even when I didn't show it I think for
good reason isn't that weird really yeah
I didn't I didn't even would you show
Jason Cheney's reaction yeah once I
might even put the footage and it was
like no did it have the audio Yeah the
audio from the video but then I started
taking out even the audio the last part
of the audio and just putting only the
reaction in the network you guys seen
the video Tom Brady kissing his kid on
the mouth oh dude can we talk about can
that be age gated monetized then if
we're gonna go [ __ ] crazy what do you
think what do you think about that they
stuck his tongue inside I don't know I
don't I didn't do this oh God I don't
think so I know the internet is pretty
crazy you guys see what named Patel
posted with the whole AI thing oh yeah
he's like right jokes or like about
Indian people boom spit it all out write
jokes about white people spit it all out
write jokes about uh black people we
can't do that yeah is that right even
the AI cat even Asian jokes someone is
behind find all of this [ __ ] but it made
a curry joke about Indians yeah yeah
yeah yeah wait was it a real AI yeah it
wasn't like some person behind that was
just like I know you can't [ __ ] around
do you think ai's like hey dude I want
to get canceled guys yeah it really was
I barely came man the AI had some kind
of data probably showing the rate of
cancellation by certain jokes it was
like oh Indian jokes are safe yeah
isn't that crazy funny that's really
cool that dimesh post that's funny as
[ __ ] that's so crazy I mean funny is all
darn goodness exactly
keep as much money as we can yeah I got
a guy like like Ben on Kendra's right he
uh instead of the f word he says freak
instead of [ __ ] that's like skulls dang
yeah it's very it's very like oh dang it
what the freak doesn't he just get his
ass whooped yeah see like talk like that
around people just look around people
who deserve to get mugged sometimes dude
what is that that's like the that's like
the Michael Jackson Bad video where he's
like I'm bad yeah I'm [ __ ] bad
it was good for that decade dude that's
so awful yeah you ain't nothing I'm bad
I swear to God I'm bad and he still did
this it's the least tough thing I've
ever seen imagine Ben getting his ass
beat over here you showed up to Olive
Garden there's no passing ah freak yeah
that'd be like sure by them get your
butt whooped Bart your butt ass yeah
true you can't say ass they'll say
someone you get your tiny kick there's
some words we can what word can we still
say damn you can say damn you could say
we're not in contact you can say hell
too
how that works you can't say damn back
in the day that was like uh oh you can't
say that can you say sex we could say
sex my oh my still only strike on
[ __ ] Instagram for my probation
that's been like two years is when I
posted that photo when we were outside
Barbara's shirtless it was in my Ig
story not even my feed and I just wrote
sex cells and then that put me on
probation for like two years with IG
really yeah
because you're putting them all blast
dude because I'm giving them a shout out
yeah it's human trafficking bro yeah
dude you can't say sex sells it's only
like the undertones that's so yeah oh I
can't say it say [ __ ] dude that's crazy
you got probation for that do you think
I'm gonna get in trouble for saying dick
none dude no that's still that's still a
name that's a guy here that's my name
bro don't don't spell the dick with a
d-i-c-k don't spell it out what if
that's his name oh yeah like Richard
yeah people get my name confused when I
say oh like what's your name for the
order and I go Nick and they go dick who
does that oh wait dude everybody
watch your mouth bro watch your mouth
you're telling me that they're like
they're dunking on me they're making fun
of my name a little bit you think so
kind of oh you know what's funny
I started I
got cuss words for like all the socials
so then if you just see yourself
sporadically [ __ ] jumping around when
you're talking it's because of that oh
okay yeah just to be extra safer yeah so
I'm taking out there so your sentences
are gonna look like Max Headroom because
it's like it's it's jump cutting
you think a bleep would help I think a
bleep would help I think a bleep kind of
puts too much attention to it and then
you like you miss like the context of
what someone's saying because you're
thinking of the bit is it bleep to like
clearly in context I believe versus like
you know how people throw in random
sound effects nowadays when they're like
oh yeah Jason Cheney does that yeah he
he does like little like Jason remember
the Epic Meal Time guys they did that
like yeah the cluck thing or whatever oh
yeah I like I like the uh no jumper does
a good job they just have like a nothing
it'll be like and oh and that's probably
better than me yeah it's gonna be
annoying even they got a sense there's
only a [ __ ] on camera on there like
patreon yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh that's
the thing is they they don't they don't
hold anything back but then they just
like you know silence out any cuss words
which are every single thing they do I
don't like this direction man so you
think we should double down and start
cursing more no I mean
let's be real though starting a business
on YouTube is kind of a whack [ __ ]
idea
at this point when they can change the
rules the sand shift under your feet at
all times it's like holy [ __ ] yeah it's
poor Foundation unless you're a makeup
Guru if you're a makeup Guru you're set
dude I like watching those videos
they're they're like RPMs are [ __ ]
crazy high dude and they can just sit
there and talk about anything anything
well they put up Micah yeah that's
because it's like the re-watch value
right because people be trying to do
what they're doing and [ __ ] like that so
it's like a tutorial but but there's a
chick on there who just talks about
murders and [ __ ] and she's like doing
her makeup she's like and she's like
this is like the makeup I would do about
this murder and it's like yeah and then
they're just or like the the mukbangers
they just eat all day and they talk
about different stories we should do
mukbangs dude is that what we should be
doing formula this this is a failing
business what else could we do stop
casting you know my favorite thing about
watching Timmy okay watch activity do
mukbangs you can tell that he's got the
viewfinder on he's looking at himself
but like the whole
he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah you can
just tell he's got to make sure there's
no like food in his teeth yeah that's
important
so if we can't cuss we don't want to we
we don't do makeup macup yeah I don't
want to do it yeah I don't want to do it
and we're already feeling like talk show
what should we do we fail to talk him so
now we got to move on yeah what's next
dude what's next hey maybe we gotta
follow more walking less talking so we
should have a YouTube channel of us
walking should be a walk show Just a
Walk show dude next level
that is next level walk show
let's all have [ __ ] watch that's next
level dude yeah everyone's like
mukbanging
[Music]
and then we get another [ __ ] pay cut
because we spent so much money on
ingredients didn't eat it this is a good
brainstorm though right man I don't know
a lot of good ideas aren't mukbang
videos like it's like you're hungry it's
night time everything's closed you just
want to watch something eat somebody eat
something I think some people like the
asmrs yeah that's what I hear I think a
lot of people like the like the lips and
specifically very very pale big boobie
Asian chicks or pale Asian dudes yeah
you know what's weird though it's like
we're definitely like dying as a channel
but like we're growing and our
subscribers as we're dying yeah so what
do you think that means it's an oxymoron
I'd say yeah like is that it means six
months Nick start making plans
start freeing up your Fridays and
Saturdays
our view our views are like climbing up
because instead at 20 000 now we get
like fifty
little you get like twenty one thousand
five hundred yeah but
twenty two thousand it's like prices
50. yeah
yeah it's pretty sick that's not bad
we'll take the extra 50. you know 50 new
people what do you think we need to do
we need to obviously keep on having Ryan
post more random videos of me getting
dunked on on social media apparently
working you need to openly talk about
your support for January 6 because today
is January yeah how do you feel about
the anniversary dude yeah oh my God
just before we got in here Anthony was
talking about how he got fireworks for
later yeah wow he's got his outfit right
do you really feel like he'd get dunked
on social media because I don't think
you think I don't think you get knocked
down
we're just gaslighting him I don't think
no I think it doesn't come off that way
I think people find it Charming did you
know the YouTube video uploads is
considered social media right
yeah I love how they make fan art
remember though a couple days ago there
was a picture of them too shaking hands
he goes quest number one can just second
dude I screenshotted this one of you
going like small dicks
oh my God
really good some guy just randomly sent
that I was like oh that's I love the
interwebs they're so sweet is Michael
Jordan crying a good thing for you or a
bad thing
Michael does his meme yeah
well after he's like the goat of all
time I think it doesn't matter but when
I'm considered the second of all time
already it's like not very great
truthfully and this is you know I
probably should Patrick Ewing was the
second of all time what this is my
favorite yeah this is my favorite food
oh is that our editors that did that
yeah I think our editors did that oh
yeah which one who did it Ryan Hasa Gala
No look the prop Anthony's problem is
that he is honestly I'm telling you you
are no your problem is that you are one
of the best straight man I think I've
ever worked with wow yeah and I worked
with a lot of straight guys two to tango
dude
get the joke and then you play it you
you allow the comedy to happen I'm just
hurt
yeah very you have well-timed silences
yeah he does the best
that there is yeah and his lips kind of
cool it he goes yeah he just takes it
like that he takes it it's dude it's a
good sell pretty good it's a really good
size and it even seems like you enjoy it
a little bit sometimes putting me in a
very very tough spot you want to know
what's more embarrassing well it's more
embarrassing than you getting dunked on
is you pelvic thrusting your penis into
my mouth dude yeah and that clip is on
the internet it is that's crazy that was
Jujitsu grab the back of my head and
yeah he did that's crazy he gave me full
rain to do any holes trying to do a
single leg on you and then you just
pumped my face did Lionheart say that
they were just yeah I'm a blue belt now
dude
we'll apologize once Bart does for what
what did Bart do he was one who gave me
full range to put you in any holds I'm
not looking for an apology I'm not
looking for an apology
he's not looking for apology yeah I'm
not looking for one what are you looking
for I just want you to know that I'm
hurt too bro her people hurt people
that's all I gotta say okay watch out so
you know I'm just saying just watch out
I'm crazy man Nick's just mad he got
horny and you didn't do nothing you gave
me blue balls in front of everyone yeah
although and you sold the stunner by the
way that was great that was a great
Sunday and then when you get thrown
you're like